will the law student interns please be
seated
thank you
that could be very much
okay
life makes me happy oh
here it is
I called to order the meeting of Friday
June 23rd for the Health and Human
Services oversights committee and would
the clerk please call the roll
representative Pearson here represent
McDonald here representative Weber
representative Edwards here
representative King here representative
Merchant
representative Murphy here Senator
Rosenwald
Senator Gray
and senator avard
and Rosenwald we have everyone
I got it okay
next on the agenda is approval of the
draft minutes for the May 19th meeting
you all should have received a copy
electronically and give you a minute or
two to review to see if there were any
suggested changes
one small error just so that everybody
doesn't pick on me right away
um
we actually had our meeting at 105 in
the PM not the am
I had am in there
oh
no next line
so there's no excuse if anyone slept
through it
okay
anything else representative Weber
you accept the message corrected
a second second any further discussion
all in favor
aye opposed thank you
the subcommittee on Alzheimer's disease
and other related dementia status
as you know from our last meeting
section 126a 15 a is a subcommittee on
Alzheimer's disease and other related
dementia this committee has been not
meeting for a while and we're asked if
it could be meeting again and so some
work has been done I circulated an email
to
Representatives on this committee
yesterday asking if there was anyone who
wished me to recommend you for the
appointment of the rep
um I already have someone else who's
interested who has been doing this in
the past but if you are interested in it
please see me before the meeting is over
because that's when I will walk up to
the speaker's office and put a name in
with that the chair recognizes Jessica
Escalon senior public policy manager for
the Alzheimer's Association please come
on up and there's only one important
preliminary task you must master and you
did it successfully think not everyone
does that welcome good morning Mr chair
and members of the committee for the
record my name is Jessica eskeland I'm
the senior public policy manager for the
Alzheimer's Association here in New
Hampshire
um as the chair
as the chair said uh I have been
you have one of two choices actually
have a choice of one of two things
either you move closer to the mic or the
mic moves closer to you no problem is
that better much better okay thank you
sorry about that
okay so again for the record Jessica
escalind with the Alzheimer's
Association here in New Hampshire uh as
the chair said we have been working to
sort of resurrect this subcommittee of
HHS oversight that is focused on
Alzheimer's disease and other dementias
this is something that Most states have
uh either a subcommittee or a commission
focused on these issues and it allows
them to do a really deep dive on these
issues that are that are becoming more
and more prevalent and certainly for our
state that is applicable so at the last
meeting of this committee I made my
presentation and the chair
um very generously said that you know
sort of keep keep up the work in terms
of doing Outreach and letting people
know that this is an effort underway uh
and I'm happy to report that
appointments have been made by several
of the associations charged with making
appointments and I spoke with the Senate
president's office yesterday and I know
that Senator avard has graciously agreed
to to serve again on the subcommittee
which is incredibly appreciated
um I am aware it was flagged for me by
Mr Williams that the website
um the subcommittee website needs
updating to reflect some of those
appointments so I will be flagging that
for the clerk's office
um and the two sort of positions that we
have yet to identify someone to fill is
the person living with Alzheimer's
disease many of the folks that I am
working directly with are not really in
a position where that would be
um something that they are are
comfortable doing so that search still
exists as well as a researcher with
Alzheimer's related expertise in base
basic transitional clinical or drug
development science still looking to
find find an individual that fits that
bill
so that's what I'm working on I
certainly would appreciate and welcome
any guidance or thoughts that the
committee members had in terms of folks
who might be appropriate but that that
is where things stand right now so the
hope is that we get those final
appointments made and would work with
Senator avard to find a time to to get
this back up and running
foreign
give you a few minutes to read through
the materials we were given
I don't see a hand I see a hand
representative Merchant
thank you
as well
but
the chair would have no difficulty in
that as an adjunct member many of these
committees rarely take votes anyway so
bringing in a few extra hands is I think
always helpful or always can be helpful
would you be amenable to that oh
absolutely I think I think the more we
can pull together the better the product
of the two pharmacists currently serving
in the House of Representatives
and all other pharmacists known to us do
you have a recommendation
type
your mic is on
and I will give you leave to do that and
just Loop me back in as you make that
known to
um yeah miss escalant anything else
good thank you wonderful thank you all
so much
and once again members of this committee
from the house we have one house
appointment so if you're interested I
don't see like anyone's
well that's
I wanted to give the opportunity to
members of this committee as well but
I've already had a conversation with
representative long about this so okay
good I think that yes representative
Edwards uh so in the minutes from last
month I said if representative long
wasn't interested and it sounds like he
is yeah it's very much so easy okay
never mind thank you
um it has long been the custom at DHHS
for the name Laurie to dominate
um but I have it on good authority that
the name Melissa or it's
elegant version morissa is the coming
name over there and to demonstrate that
today we have associate commissioner
Marissa hen a jolly good fellow fellow
to make the commissioner's reports
good morning
and yes thank you on I want to send
regards from commissioner Lori Weber who
has the governor's Commission on Alcohol
and Other Drugs happening simultaneously
so and first I think want to while we
won't go in depth on this just want to
acknowledge the historic bipartisan
budget that was signed this week and
it's important implications for dhhs's
Mission
um and um and the people we we serve so
so that's not the topic of the updates I
was asked to provide but I think it
Bears mentioning and and our gratitude
to those involved
so there were two topics that
um I was asked to provide some brief
updates and answer any questions about
today one of which may actually kind of
shorten your agenda because I thought I
would cover the Youth Development Center
here
um in lieu of covering it as an agenda
item although happy to go into more
depth on any of this
but the first topic um is the
Department's opening of New Hampshire's
first ever psychiatric Residential
Treatment Facility or prtf
um this is a huge moment for our
children's system of care
um in the behavioral health realm
um just about a month ago the state had
a ribbon cutting the governor joined us
others from the community leaders like
yourself representative Pearson to open
this new unit if you will but really a
separate and distinct part of that
Hampstead campus which is offering our
first ever highest level of Residential
Care this is designed for youth who are
between the ages of 5 and 21
whose Behavioral Health needs cannot be
met in a community setting or in our
other existing levels of Residential
Care in many cases these are youth who
are stepping down from an inpatient
psychiatric level of care but not quite
ready to return to their home
communities
um and it's a very family-centered model
of care as well families are involved at
every step
um I think one of the key things that
makes this such a huge step forward for
the State of New Hampshire is the fact
that previously when a young person
needed this level of care because it
wasn't available in New Hampshire and
because there are long long wait lists
and unavailability in our neighboring
states we often had to send them to
States Far Far Away thousands of miles
away which is not conducive to the types
of connections with the community that
we are all committed to and the
day-to-day involvement of their families
so this is a really important step for
us and um and we are slowly ramping up
to make sure operations are smooth it
will eventually have 12 beds currently
there are five youth there today
um and week by week as we get in Rhythm
we will we will keep increasing that
census
um so I'll pause there on the prtf and
see if there are any questions
representative Edwards
the this facility is it isn't secure
so it is
um it is not it is it is secure in so
far as it is designed
um to keep youth within the facility
it's not like a place people can come
and go
um so it offers a delayed egress store
um partly to meet fire code so it's not
a completely shut down lock door in the
way of an inpatient psychiatric unit
um but it is still um has many security
units it also is compliant with all of
the aspects of the zero suicide model in
the sense of all of the aspects of the
facility are designed to ensure safety
for a population that is at risk for
suicide
follow up thank you so uh what I what I
think I'm hearing in that is the patient
cannot leave without being permitted to
leave that the doors are locked until
unless there's an emergency that's
exactly right okay so then
um the other part of this is
um commitment Authority uh to what
extent uh can the patient refuse to be
committed to this level of care uh to
what extent are parent approvals and
permissions required to what extent does
the state or the medical community make
the determination yeah so all of the
youth who are um served in the prtf are
there voluntarily meaning they are there
based on their own understanding and
commitment to treatment as well as that
of um parents and Guardians in the case
of minors that's a little bit in
contrast to the option to explore or
involuntary Care at the inpatient level
that you may be familiar with which is
extremely rare that we're in a situation
of um of Youth requiring
um to be admitted involuntarily but for
the prtf it is 100 voluntary
okay
so yeah that's also encouraging to know
that the committee overseeing it is now
going to have public meetings and
listening sessions and talking sessions
with the residents of Hampstead that's
right and actually that connects to the
second topic which is also centered on
that campus
um which is the Youth Development Center
um so as many of you are deeply involved
with especially representative Edwards
um this past legislative session was a
very important one in terms of moving
our department and our Collective Vision
forward for moving from a correctional
model of care into a therapeutic smaller
but architecturally secure facility
for youth involved in the Juvenile
Justice System
um so through passage of HB 49 we
receive legislative approval as well as
the Appropriations to build this new
center and to close the current the
current YDC facility and so just wanted
to update this group since a lot has
happened and we also did provide a
report a letter to you representative
Pearson on the progress that is made but
just wanted to highlight a few aspects
and answer any questions
um so the first step since passage of HB
49 was that we brought on smrt
Architects and Engineers to complete a
site assessment analysis to determine
the feasibility of three potential
locations for this Youth Development
Center which representative Pearson is
uh is just was displaying
um and they did a very in-depth analysis
um many technical specifications
examination of different criteria Etc
and we as a department released that
um just about a month ago
um and that assessment concluded that
the Hampstead Hospital and residential
treatment facility campus that I was
just telling you about the prtf residing
on would be the best option among those
three for the location nation of this
future YDC
in addition
um since we last met
um under sb1 which passed prior to hb49
a commission has been formed
um that is chaired by Senator Birdsell
um to study the community impacts and
various considerations of that site and
The Wider Community context so things
like Public Safety Etc and that
commission which I sit on had its first
meeting just about a week ago and to
your point representative Pearson is
going to be a crucial group for
providing it includes a number of
different leaders from law enforcement
from the provider advocacy community
members of the House and Senate Etc to
ensure that we are taking a thoughtful
approach as we launch into this next
phase of design and construction of the
facility so a report is due by November
it sounds like Senator bird cell is
pretty committed to getting that in
sooner and part of the reason for that
is that we're we're trying to move
pretty quickly here
um one of the timing constraints is that
the federal arpa dollars the coven
relief dollars that are being
um used in large part to build this
facility need to be spent by 2026 and
need to be um need to be dedicated uh by
the end of 2025. so in order to do that
with a with a facility of this scope and
size and complex population we need to
hit the ground running on the design
process and that's exactly what we've
done and what we will engage this
Commission in
um the other update is last Wednesday
about 10 days ago governor and Council
approved our contract our selection of
HDR as the Architecture Firm to do the
design process for this um for this
build and they have a long history of
work both in the Juvenile Justice space
but also in New Hampshire and so now
it's a matter of knitting together all
the pieces ensuring that the voice of
local community Through Community
meetings and consultation are very much
present as well as the work of the
commission which is helping deepen our
focus on the the critical aspects and
impacts of this facility but we'll be
moving quickly but feel good about the
process and the the effectuation of the
vision that we've shared for a long time
any questions on YDC
representative Edwards
is there anything that the legislature
can do to eliminate any potential
barriers or roadblocks that would slow
or impede the design and and
construction process what can we do to
help and stay out of the way
you want an HP 49 was a was a critical
first level of leadership to setting us
up and providing the funding to do this
work well but
um I think right now we're all largely
on the same page I mean I think that
we're seeing we have a good precedent
with the forensic hospital that's being
built here in Concord to realize that
it's it's critical to be consultative
with everyone who's involved everyone
who's impacted early and often and that
will continue to be our approach not
just with elected representatives but
with local community with um with with
schools with law enforcement Etc so I'll
let you know but I think for right now
we're grateful for the support that's
even gotten us to this point
representative Weber
thank you and could you just remind me
of the timeline
um you said funds designated by 2025 I'm
I'm hoping they will be Des I mean I
know that there's been an appropriation
but uh if you could just give me a quick
overview of the timeline yeah I thought
you might ask that so I actually brought
it um so we are currently in what is
called the pre-design phase which is
June to August 2023 and by the way I'll
send this around so it gets captured in
your minutes so this summer is
pre-design Phase August to October 2023
is the schematic phase where this design
actually comes to life through actual uh
Vision documents October to January will
be our completion of our design
development um don't ask me what that
means The Architects tell me it's the
next phase in bringing together the
pre-design and schematic
um and then we go on and I should
mention by the way that this is not
reliant on my expertise as a engineer
which are non-existent we are working
with the division of Public Works and
Das to oversee all the different aspects
of this design and build so January to
May is when the construction
preparation process begins that's when
we will be procuring for we'll do a
competitive procurement for a contractor
to actually build the facility we'll be
doing all the necessary checks and
engineer civil engineering and so forth
to prepare for construction next January
through May we expect to bring a
contract a proposed contract to governor
and Council next summer
and have a notice to proceed immediately
thereafter so essentially that would set
us up to begin construction
next fall and be halfway done hopefully
by early 2025 fully completed by the end
of 2025 so that's that you sort of see
where the federal covid money deadlines
fit into that it sets us up to be able
to be clear about how we're dedicating
them and then actually expend the dollar
dollars by by the deadline which is uh
end of 2026.
um so our our hope is to be completed by
November 2025 and begin moving in youth
um at the end of 2025 giving us a little
bit more time to do all the bookkeeping
and ensure all payments are made within
that Federal deadline does that help yes
thank you very much I'm I'm although the
federal deadlines are really important
and much more uh interested in when it's
going to be open and receiving the youth
who need the treatment exactly Senator
Rosenwald thank you thank you Mr chair
um
so we appropriated a little under 22
million dollars House Bill 2 made a
further restriction on those funds and
said it really had to only be arpa funds
is that
amount of money
um going to be all that is needed for
that project because there's no
opportunity at this point for any other
funds yeah my understanding is that
based on our current estimates we have
updated with dasp or the changes in
supply chain and labor on that we are in
good shape with that amount
representative Edwards
okay so so I am interested in the money
part as well
um when we're talking about Federal
money oftentimes what they use uh the
end of a year as 30 September
and it sounded to me like in your use of
the phrase end of the year you're
talking about the end of December so so
are you I I assume you all are paying
attention to if there's any sort of
fiscal year deadlines that come before
the end of a calendar year
and I don't want to speak incorrectly
but I will assure you that our finance
team does have
um or does have the dates correct so but
good point
any other questions
anything else from the Commissioner's
Office no thanks for your time good
thank you Dr hen appreciate it
EOS surgeons generals advisory on social
media and youth mental health chair
recognizes Patricia Tilley from the
division of Public Health and Jennifer o
Higgins senior policy analyst division
for Behavioral Health
good morning thank you chair thank you
for welcoming us to the committee today
again I'm Trish Tilley director of
Public Health
and I'm Jenny O Higgins a senior policy
analyst and legislative liaison for
Behavioral Health so thank you good
morning
um thanks again for this opportunity
Jenny and I have put together a few
slides in the slide deck that you have
in front of you to address the growing
concerns that we all share around social
media and mental health I especially
want to thank representative Edwards who
has been interested in this issue for
quite some time and he has urged the
department to take action in this space
we have done so much in the past couple
of years to address the acute mental
health needs of young people and adults
in the state we're just hearing about it
from associate commissioner hen right
now but the evidence is growing that
there is more to be done to build
protective factors long before there are
acute needs that require complex
expensive treatment and interventions
this is why it makes sense to look at
this issue around social media with a
public health framework using data to
develop smart prevention messaging and
appropriate policies you have a ton of
slides in front of you and we are not
going to go through each one of those
we're happy always to take questions and
have more conversation but I understand
you have a very long agenda and it is a
beautiful June day outside so we're
going to focus on three things we're
going to focus a little bit on level
setting what the data is some of the
that highlights where some of our
concerns are we're going to focus on the
surgeon general's advisory and three
what our plans are for addressing it in
New Hampshire especially through the
governor's new executive order as you
flip to slides two three and four you'll
see what you already know screens are
everywhere and social media is
ubiquitous the American Academy of
Pediatrics has been focused on issues of
media exposure long before the Advent of
Tick Tock but now that more than 80 90
percent of Youth are on their personal
devices for hours and hours a day the
problem is compound founded youth are
bombarded with targeted messaging and
the algorithms themselves are designed
to keep you scrolling and to put eyes on
products
and to promote potentially harmful
messaging
Slide Five in particular illustrates
that one of the differences between our
old worries about media and TV screen
time for example is the very
personalized algorithms and the
opportunity for direct for harmful
direct messaging girls in particular are
in the crosshairs with almost 30 percent
of girls in New Hampshire High Schools
reporting cyber bullying it is
interesting that it appears that this
happens more at younger ages 9th grade
has the highest rates again this is
youth risk behavioral Behavior survey
the survey that we do in high schools
across the state we all lived through
Middle School all of us although it was
quite a long time ago for some of us and
those early years but many of us even
then we're just sort of happy to get
through the school day the difference
now is that those messages
and potentially bullying Behavior
follows you the rest of the day no
matter where you are you're at home
you're at night in bed you wake up in
the morning that device is there and
there's an opportunity for those
messages harmful Behavior to follow you
wherever
and of course the most concerning data
that we've seen is around the dramatic
increase in the number of Youth who are
feeling sad or hopeless this pattern
began well before the pandemic although
we've sort of talked about it in the
framework of the pandemic but you can
see on on slide six that that trend line
was going in the wrong direction before
um and we are now in an unfathomable
place where more than half of girls high
school girls are feeling sad or hopeless
in contrast to cyber bullying the data
suggests or appears to have more of a
cumulative effect where older students
are impacted more than younger students
and I know Jenny you want to talk a
little bit about this and and yeah I
think just in terms of our crisis lines
for Behavioral Health we're seeing
similar Trends to what you're seeing
here in the youth risk behavior survey
of who is calling I also will say that
we and we'll get into this in in just a
moment too where teens also find out
about resources and ask for help through
these their devices right and so that's
another critical important piece to talk
about what are some of the positive
aspects because they're not going away
so what are the ways that people also
access resources and help but when we
look at our data from our crisis lines
in particular the crisis text line the
people that are texting from New
Hampshire are 14 to 17 year old girls
primarily so that does line up right
with this information so I think that so
leads to tell
someone if there is any good news in
here is we know what can protect kids
and one of those things is having access
to resources having access to 988 in a
way in which that is comfortable for
those 14 to 17 year old girls to use
they're already texting anyway that's a
way that they feel comfortable getting
information we also know that we have
other things that are protective for
kids positive high quality relationships
with their peers and with their parents
connectivity and and believing you can
make a difference helps build resiliency
social connection which is the number
and variety and the quality of those
relationships that meet your own
personal needs is important to kids it's
important for adults not only is it
protective for the wear and tear of
social media but it is also protective
of things like anxiety depression heart
disease diabetes those social positive
connections are really really important
there's always going to be kids who need
a certain level of of intensive
treatment but from a prevention and a
protective lens there are opportunities
to ameliorate the crisis and the and try
and get this curve to bend in a
different way
and so Vivek Murphy who happens to be
one of my favorite people has put out
that he's the Surgeon General of the
United States he's put out an advisory
on social media and youth mental health
and I encourage you to check out his
full advisory it is available online and
also while you're doing that to peek
over to some of the priorities that is
within the surgeon general's office
right now that address a multitude of
issues that are plaguing us today but um
that include youth mental health but
also things like social connection you
can't think of the two without each
other and so this is where we get into
some of the emerging data on the
negative impact of social media one of
the unique aspects of social media is
the pervasive way it promotes comparison
to social groups and networks and this
can lead to a host of issues from
disordered eating body dysmorphia
depression and self-harm especially
among vulnerable youth you know there's
a quote comparison is the thief of Joy I
think Mark Twain said death of Joy I am
sure that is attributed to a number of
dead white men from a number of folks
but we understand that that comparison
leads to some of these issues and while
you've described the benefits as as
Jenny said from social media the
positivity is oh is not always unanimous
teens say they feel overwhelmed by the
drama that they see on social media they
have pressure to post content that it
likes or comments and that moves them in
a certain way to post more provocative
images and some report that these
platforms just make them feel worse
about their own life and while we have
some data in studies to inform us and to
inform the Surgeon General I know in
particular that Jenny is a huge advocate
in this space for ensuring that we
better understand from youth themselves
what it means to them to have this
little device in their hand that gives
them Kings of Joy but also opens up to
to other impacts yeah so I think to that
point I think it's really important just
like in all of our work in Behavioral
Health we're constantly talking about
voices of lived experience right and
there are some times with our children
where if my toddler doesn't want to ride
in their car seat and says that's
uncomfortable I know better and I have
to keep them safe there are other times
when you're engaging with adolescents
when you work directly with adolescents
they are younger grown-ups they can make
a lot of decisions on their own they can
do many of the things that adults can do
and we have to recognize that their
brains are not fully developed and of
course have to help them navigate this
but I do think it's really critical when
making policy or when parenting at these
age group that we have open
communication and that we hear from
voices of young people so I really and
enjoyed reading more about slides 12 and
13 where you have a Pew research study
that is what teens are telling you right
so you'll see in there some of that data
around when they feel overwhelmed when
they they're comparing themselves to
others and then you'll also see on that
slide 13 that there are times where
social media helps teens feel more
connected helps them find resources
helps them be able to express creativity
so I do think we have to find balance as
opposed to saying because of potential
negative harms we take these things away
when we have to really make sure we
educate young people to help them make
informed decisions about their health
just as we would in every other kind of
area yeah you know I think it's
important on that to also acknowledge
what we still don't know so we don't
know how you know in person versus
digital interactions impact your health
we don't exactly know how that happens
we don't exactly know how social media
builds or erodes social connectedness
there are lots of areas for research
lots of information that we still don't
know
um and we really don't know what exactly
what type of content and at what
frequency generates the most harm there
is a lot to learn there's a lot to learn
from youth themselves and there's a lot
to learn from sort of Greater research
as we move forward so I think at the end
of the day we need to balance the good
and the bad I think that's our job every
day that is your job as policy makers
it's our job here in public health or in
the Department of Health and Human
Services is to balance this um difficult
murky emerging area that we've all come
to live in so what can kids and families
do right now so granted we don't know
all the answers we need to hear more
from youth but what what are some of the
things that we can do right now this
very second so first of all I think we
need a model responsible social media
behavior and that goes for Mom and Dad
in addition to kids I know I have a gen
Z daughter she is quick to call me a
screen Ager that's at the what we say in
the house I had she says ma stop being a
screenager as I am scrolling and
answering emails perhaps from some of
you while we're eating dinner I think
it's important to model that kind of
boundaries about when it's okay and when
it's not okay to be on your screens we
need to learn about technology and the
ways in which media is designed to
market products and move behaviors I
think
um you know corporate world is Madison
Ave is very bright there's a reason that
we buy a lot of things and why we're
moved to do that and I think it's
important for us to learn that those
that is often behind some of the things
that we see on on our screens we need to
understand how those algorithms work we
all need to set some boundaries for use
Mom Dad kids everybody about tech free
zones when we use it when we don't use
it and have conversations about that
that um take in account what youth need
and want knowing that brain development
isn't quite done yet and what parents
can do to model in that space it's
important for us to report cyber
bullying and any online abuse we need to
make that uh known we need to make that
be something that kids feel comfortable
telling their parents about and really
that has repercussions at the end of the
day and then something I know that many
of you in this room are very passionate
about is really about protecting and
promoting digital privacy I think that
that's um an area that we have a lot
more work to do on but it's critical if
we want to be protective of kids so one
of the good things is is that we are
okay
we have not choreographed this this in
any way shape or form so one of the
other pieces of good news is that there
are Blueprints and we don't need to
start from scratch when we talk about
education for youth in particular
um there are some guidelines that are
already out there that focus on um where
in sort of children's developmental
develop you know age and development
what's important for them to learn what
we should talk about how help you know
what healthy behaviors are and what
impacts those healthy behaviors so we're
very fortunate that some of those
curricula already exists out there and
are useful for us and and quite frankly
are already happening in many schools in
the state for a second so you will see
that we put in here some of the national
standards and across the board in each
of these different you know you should
know this in your health education by
this age level it starts from an
understanding of identifying ways in
which media impacts Health behaviors and
it moves towards analyzing those and
evaluating how they're affecting you so
it's really teaching critical thinking
skills but around this topic and that
those will help us to set what are the
things that our youth need to know and
our families need to know in this space
we're also really lucky to have a
homegrown non-profit in New Hampshire
that's a national leader in this area
Media power youth has National
evidence-based programs on the samsa
registry around how do how does media
literacy impact health behavior so very
happy to be working with them as well
absolutely I can't underscore that
enough Media power youth is a phenomenal
organization based out of Manchester and
they have been doing this work long
before a tick tock Revolution is this
listed in the slides anywhere that would
that Medium how are you no it isn't but
I can send it we need to power youth
Media power youth
why not let's invite them
representative uh Consular attorney
Edwards let's invite the people who just
spoke of okay they're a great
organization and have worked closely
with the Department in lots of areas um
in our injury prevention in prevention
work for drug and alcohol they're
fabulous
um so Governor sununu jumped on board as
well earlier this month as you know and
issued an executive order that primarily
does three things one it looks at
curriculum so much like we just spoke
about it directs the New Hampshire
Department of Education with support
from DHHS to make recommendations and
build developmentally appropriate
Frameworks based on existing School
criteria
two it directs us to look at the data
DHHS and the New Hampshire Department of
Ed will review existing research and the
harms of social media this has already
begun and three there's a Communications
and a public engagement plan and I know
that that was a particular interest to
representative Edwards when we had our
earlier conversations and so the
governor's order also directs Department
of Ed HHS do it to coordinate and
develop a communication plan to both
inform and engage parent and youth voice
as we move through this process there's
90 days we have to put something
together
um the Commissioners have already begun
meeting on this they're uh the work
really begins in Earnest in July so a
lot more to come in that space
so as we wrap up
um I know you have a long agenda you
know I think uh we have a couple of
messages that we want to make sure that
we move forward there's an analogy
that's been floating around my head that
is imperfect but I think it's helpful
which is social media is a little bit
like a car so when we think about cars
from a from a public health perspective
um we've made the car itself safer
um parents and families have a
responsibility to work with their youth
to get them ready to drive that car and
we have policies in place as well to
also ensure the safety of everyone who's
on the road and I think it's important
to think about it that way that the work
is not solely on the backs of Youth and
parents to fix social media there's a
part to play around education guidance
boundaries but there's other work that
can also be done not only here in New
Hampshire but elsewhere to make sure
that the product itself is safer as well
as to ensure that that we're all safe
when we get on the road or scroll
through that screen and I know that
Jenny probably has a couple other
takeaways that she wants to leave you
with yeah I think it is just we are
thinking about sort of that awareness
through that public information campaign
as part of the executive order we're
thinking about that education and
mentioning that we already have some
curriculum and some national standards
and I think the piece around policy that
you know for you all to be thinking a
lot about is around transparency and
algorithm accountability to the
platforms and around Online safety
measures that can include things like
content filtering measures to protect
and prevent grooming and Reporting
mechanisms for inappropriate content
right there's certain specific things
that do have to do with policy and if we
have sort of that multi-tiered approach
where we have awareness and we have
education and we have good policy will
be moving in the right direction
so I would just end by saying it's all
about Connections that's what families
and youth can do right now is build
those positive social connections I
think there are some things again that a
policy level that is going to emerge
over time and making sure that we've got
great education so that's it from us
we're happy to answer anything or engage
representative Edwards thank you Mr
chair there's there's as I go through
this presentation I got seven points I
think I'd like to make in uh that our
time has been mentioned a few times so
maybe some of these could just be
statements for me as opposed to
questions go ahead
um okay on on page 14 on uh what we
still don't know uh one of the things
that I think is just screaming to be
added to what we don't know is uh the
correlation between the depression and
sadness that's being triggered by social
media and uh substance misuse because I
I suspect that there's probably an
extremely strong correlation to
substance misuse and if we want to have
fewer people abusing drugs that this is
actually a key component of a state
strategy just that's just my thought
there
going on to
page 19 on the executive order
some of this is outside of your scope
and and maybe Mr Williams and I could
talk about it later but but I from
reading these things these feel like
all elements of existing law that the
governor has put into
an executive order in other words he's
not doing anything here to make new law
uh that he's got the legal framework to
do all of this is that that's your
understanding that's my understanding
okay so
um
so that opens up a few other questions
because we know that other states are
moving to to regulate social media I
think Utah Louisiana are a couple
so so I would want to start having the
dialogue about what is outside of this
executive order that the governor's
office would like the legislation
legislature to begin to consider and
again that's not your role but but do
you know who in his office has point on
this issue
believe it's Adam but we'll find out
okay thank you I I I'd like to have that
conversation and then on the final
thoughts uh you know I I just I don't
want the boys to be overlooked I under I
mean I don't think you said that but you
you spoke twice about the importance of
taking care of our our young girls in
this issue you didn't mention boys I'm
sure that was just an oversight so I I
just want to make sure we don't overlook
the boys uh on your second bullet it
says refrain from fear-based narratives
and I would say I would want our
narratives to be reality based if
there's stuff we need to be afraid of
Let's Not Be tiptoeing around it let's
let's go ahead and if if if if there's
something to fear let's be honest with
people I I don't want this to become too
sugar coated and then the the youth
youth and parents should not bear all of
the responsibility in making online
space is safer that sort of opens up the
question of you know what does that mean
who who else needs to be involved how do
we come up with a comprehensive strategy
of involving all of the people that
should be bearing responsibility so so
those those are kind of my comments that
I just would like to get into the record
and maybe I can work with representative
King to get that into the minutes but um
is there any of that that you want to
respond to uh first of all we're very
concerned about boys as well as girls so
thank you for uh but we are particularly
in what we wanted to highlight is that
there are disparate outcomes that we
have girls are experiencing things
differently than boys that's not to say
that boys aren't also experiencing those
things so just for for clarity around
that and then at the end you know I
think our idea about who Bears
responsibility that really is an open
question to everyone in this room and
you know society as a whole but really
to everyone that that we uh what we
would suggest in the department that
this isn't a problem that can be solved
simply on the backs of parents and kids
that this is much bigger and it is a
social media is a designed product and
so much like my car analogy again
imperfect there are pieces where policy
where products need to be safer where we
need to enjoy and ensure that
um you know kids are using them also
appropriately
so additionally it is that what we were
thinking there is that the social media
platforms themselves bear some
responsibility to making their products
safe and we bear some responsibility to
having good policy in place that ensures
safety including some of those
accountability transparency and safety
measures that I were talking about
earlier so that's why I mean yes Youth
and families but they can't sort of do
it alone it has to be a multi-pronged
approach and then just to respond to the
piece about the reality based versus
fear-based narratives the reason to
include refraining from fear-based
narratives is specific research about
how youth respond to fear-based
narratives and especially because that
frontal lobe is not fully developed
fear-based narratives just don't work
for youth so that was a very that was
more specific than sort of broad base
it's not all that we wouldn't want it to
be reality based we just want to make
sure that any education that we're
providing will actually be received and
retained by young people
hmm
my fear would be that while it is true
we have to involve more people than
parents and kids my fear would be we
overshoot it and the government so
clamps down on things that they're
controlling and there is that fine
balance that only exists in theory but
we have to strive for representative
Murphy
thank you um a comment and question you
know on page four I'm just curious
because you talked about high school
students that spend three more hours
that's a big number in the high 70s for
every subcategory that's mentioned there
but as I watched my grandchildren on
their iPads a lot of their time is spent
doing research homework looking at the
Bruins highlights the next morning Etc
so I'm kind of curious as well as to
what is the absolute number of hours
that we are aware of that you know kids
at that level are spending time on the
tick tocks and the social media and the
bullying and stuff like that so more
that's one question but my other one is
I feel like we're at the beginning of a
a problem that we've identified and also
now are looking for the research the
understanding of it I mean I was
listening to a podcast about the
dopamine receptors and the levels in
these young kids brains and how it
affects their use or non-use of you know
iPads so my question is do we have
either nationally or locally a group or
a definitive strategic plan moving
forward as to how to address this or are
we just
first we're at a stage of identifying
right now and we don't have a really
strategic plan going forward and should
we
I think on the first one I'll just jump
in around the sort of number of hours or
what they're doing on there I think
that's a really important point is that
while it there are some pieces where we
just don't want them to be used to be on
screens all the time it is actually less
about number of hours and more about
what they're doing on there right so it
is um we do know that there are lots of
learning games for young people there
are lots of ways they're healthy
connections to their friends and peers
and that's all really important to keep
in mind and part of the educational
piece and part of the safety measures
piece and to put in into place is around
content as opposed to just is there a
right number of hours also just like
everything else it's very different
person to person right and so there are
ways that our schools are communicating
with with parents and with youth through
social media our clubs you know our our
sports teams are also using these
platforms to communicate so there's a
lot of Engagement going on that's about
being a part of a team or about being
you know a part of 4-H or all these
different sort of things that happen on
social media or to your point are doing
homework engaging with teachers things
like that that may not necessarily all
be detrimental to their health so this
is a complex balance I I couldn't agree
more thank you Jenny said that
beautifully and you know I'll just note
that this three hours per day on screen
time this is a measure that has been
measured for
um well over a decade in youth risk
behavioral and it actually came out of
TV watching and the amount of
commercials you saw that was the
research that came up with this magic
three hours so our media consumption has
changed so much there I think what it
does is indicates what we all see which
is we're all spending a lot of time
scrolling but that scrolling has a lot
of different content on it and that's
the research that needs to be done which
comes back to your your last point of is
there a strategic plan and you know I'm
certainly not aware that there is an
overarching a strategic plan that's
addressing this I think in New Hampshire
we are at the beginning we know that
schools and Community organizations have
certainly addressed it in the ways in
which they can I think the gov owners
order at least um while does not go far
it certainly gathers the appropriate
state agencies together in a room to
start having important conversations
Senator Rosenwald thank you Mr chair I'm
glad you brought up the fact that kids
are doing other things on their screens
that's how they're watching television
and
they're exposed to a lot of popular
culture that isn't social media through
television through movies and
I don't feel like I could make a
determination that social media is good
or bad but I don't think I think I think
your data doesn't show here
that it's harming kids in fact it should
seems to show the opposite on slide 12
and 13 the positive kids are reporting
are like twice
as high as the negative so I kind of
wonder if it if we're focusing just on
social media we're leaving out
video games which are bigger than movies
living out television we're leaving our
movies and maybe we're narrowing our
Focus yeah and we're gonna miss the
point entirely so I don't think your
data shows
I want you 've been trying to suggest I
just want those two those two slides
that are youth voice and have their
perception of whether it's positive or
negative influence on them which I think
is really critical for us to consider
there is data that we that is in here as
well to suggest that there's negative
impact on young people's mental health
and so it's a balance of finding what
are the positives and what are the
negatives and including that youth voice
in that as well
um but we also can send you the links to
the research in here so that you have
that to dig in deeper or you know get
you more information about it I think
that would be helpful because I don't
think your data support your point and
you know I agree
um thank you for for acknowledging that
in here I think this is also a place
where the data has to catch up so you
know we have to have ways in which to
collect that data get that data analyze
it there have been
um genius noted there are a number of
reports that the Department of Justice
has already put together are in
preparation for this executive order for
the work there that really looks at
specific harms but these are individual
studies
um I think we need to go through those
and better understand how applicable or
how broad-ranging those those may be we
don't have the tools right now for
example in yrbs we don't have the
questions in 20 you know we can't go
back to 2021 and rejigger those
questions to get at some of the things
that I think we all want to know
I think also ultimately the surgeon
general's report said we can't we don't
have enough evidence to conclude that
this is safe for children right and so
you're point taken that we're both
saying there's potential harms and
there's potential benefits and our
approach is going to have to take into
consideration all of that complexity
representative King
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my uh somewhat lengthy question
or lead into the question anyway but I
want to I want to compliment you on a a
very well done presentation and I
realize this is just the identification
stage but this has this has prompted a
lot of uh brainstorming in my own head
um and I think you made a great point
about how we used to leave school and
school was left behind now it's
continually in the in the child's uh
life and and I do believe that this
really does point to where we're seeing
a lot of problems and I hear more
bullying in the schools from kids that
that I'm connected to and I'm hearing
where conflict resolution is a problem
and uh and this study definitely shows
where the this is a problem some some
people in my community of Milford
sahegan Valley area
are trying to figure out how to help
kids in this area and I'm really excited
to see that you have a curriculum that's
uh part of what I believe is going to
come out of this in the future and so my
question is kind of in line with what
representative Edwards said earlier is
how can we become a part of the solution
thank you
all of us that's continuing our own our
own education on these topics right so
as this curriculum develops it's
something where when when I talk to
Media power youth I said I need to go
through all these classes basically all
the different programs that you have for
young people I gotta get I gotta go
through them too right so I think this
is going to be just a learning curve for
all of us together and that we need to
continue to involve Young Voices in
every one of those conversations so when
we build curriculum without young people
um then we build something where they
may reflect on it and say I would never
do that right so we may say let's
practice how we're going to say no to
our friend during peer pressure or
something like this and they say I would
never do it like that but I might do it
these four other ways so when we write
curriculum with them we make something
that works and I think that's going to
be a really critical piece of what we
move forward with as well
representative McDonald
thank you Mr chairman uh and again I
want to compliment you on this also it's
a lot of good information in here and
you give us a good breakdown on um
information about you know gender a
grade in School race ethnicity I was
talking about other demographic factors
like socioeconomic status if if we have
data breakdowns along those lines also
and perhaps other demographic breakdowns
sure so thank you for that question
um so we have some other ways we can
break this is um the data in the
beginning in particular the New
Hampshire youth risk behavioral survey
yrbs we can cut that in several ways
um we can do uh perhaps less around
socioeconomic because again it's a
child's report but there are other
demographics for example children who
identify as lgbtq plus we know that they
are certainly experiencing mental health
crises right now as well
um so we have that information again
race ethnicity and age is probably the
most stand way to look at that right now
especially when we're thinking about
curricula in the school and ensuring
that we're getting the right curricula
at the right developmental level at the
right ages but there are some other ways
data um some of the smaller studies as I
mentioned to Senator Rosenwald again are
limited but we have to be able to use
these broader survey base where we have
larger groups of individuals there's a
lot more work that really needs to be
done is there anything you would add
okay thank you follow up
the reason I I mentioned socioeconomic
and economic in particular is obviously
a wealthier family there's more
electronic toys a child might have
access to than in a more disadvantaged
household and I think that information
would be helpful if we could get
something like that absolutely although
what we have found is that again across
um most kids have a phone you know it
may be an older iPhone than a newer
iPhone it may not have three cameras on
the back you may have two cameras on the
back but they have a phone so that is
part that we is part of the mix right
now
representative Weber
uh and and before I ask my question I
will just second that as as somebody I
serve as a casa and uh the the
um
Arrangements that people make uh that
parents make so that they have phones
and their kids have phones are occupy a
great deal of their daily lives
um and uh are are absolutely core and
Central to their daily lives uh I guess
I I want to reiterate the thing that I
think several of us have already uh
begun to to put into the conversation
which is a reminder directly to you
because we've talked about it in terms
of the governor's office and other other
ways
I so applaud the fact that there's a lot
in here that are non-legislative
Solutions and non-legislative action uh
because the first thing I think when
somebody proposes a bill is is there a
way to do this without making it into a
law
uh but I think all of us want to be very
clear that if you have
suggestions or requests for legislative
action that we start hearing about them
early so we can development develop them
early because we have a very short
window of opportunity in September in
order to file bills and it's an
opportunity I don't want to miss if
there's something coming down the road
so I just want to add my voice to that
as a as a please think about it
proactively and early and and let us
know because as a legislature we also
want to help be part of that solution
thank you representative weather I know
that at least the governor's group that
has come pulling together you know is
working over the summer so I think in
part so that we have some time to think
if there are policies that need to be
addressed the chair has a question is
there a group that has come together say
either in a middle school or a high
school of a group of students who say
we've had enough of this and they come
together as perhaps a 12 step group
holding each other accountable or a
group that understands and digs deeper
into what you presented so they can be
peer informing it's not like a head
squad on this I mean I think there's
just a number of amazing youth serving
organizations and youth groups and many
of which are sort of Grassroots as well
coming from young people through we can
connect also with our Public Health
regions with our drug-free community
grantees and on and on to kind of get a
better understanding of what's the youth
voice and youth pulse on this in New
Hampshire again also the curriculum that
Media power that I mentioned earlier
that is an evidence-based curriculum is
actually written with New Hampshire
middle schoolers so that's also just an
interesting and kind of neat piece that
they wanted to be involved in and gave
voice to that the existing curriculum
that we do are you telling me or I am I
wanting you to tell me that there's a
growing number of kids who are
recognizing all of this stuff and said
we've had it we're not going to take it
anymore and we're going to fight back
and we're going to look out for others
who we can bring on board I don't think
that youth are saying hey we're done
with social media
stay healthy and safe and what do we
need to know and questioning where it's
challenging them and where they find it
helpful and connecting right and so
they're asking the same questions of
themselves and then looking to yes
educate themselves and their peers and
hopefully some are influencers yes and
other questions representative Edwards
this is a segue off of I think
representative Weber's comment about
what we might do uh legislatively and
what we ought not to do I I I wanted to
make sure also that I I thanked Miss
Tilly because she was very open to
beginning to discuss this months ago and
I don't know if the governor's idea came
organically in a parallel way or if it
was connected in some way I it doesn't
much matter but I do appreciate the fact
that you're willing to engage this issue
and begin talking about it months ago
and in our research together I think
we've looked at two states that have
passed social media laws restricting
access to minors and we looked at the
clinical research that they use to
support their legislation and I have to
tell you that I was frankly disappointed
in how the other legislatures
used really probably I would call it to
be fair or nice about it they use their
own legislative experience and judgment
more than they seem to be relying on
existing research to drive the content
Contours of their bills so I I would
hope that we have efforts and approaches
to stay on top of the emerging research
on this so that the research can inform
the legislature on what we ought to do I
don't want to do this seat of the pants
I I wanted I want to do it right so if
you will stay on that
I'd appreciate that and and again thank
you for for being willing to get
involved early
thank you it has been a pleasure in the
um and you're absolutely right the the
research is developing to Senator
rosenwald's point to yours there's inter
there's interesting information out
there the surgeon Generals Report which
we'll send out also links a number of
studies that talk about some of the
negative impacts again their their
individual studies so I think we are in
that exploration phase certainly through
the summer to synthesize what is out
there right now and what are the holes
that we still need to learn
representative Merchant
thank you Mr chair
first of all thank you for the report
it's very informative and very useful
although a lot of this is talking about
the issue and trying to find ways made
to prevent the issue of bullying and so
forth I commend it
in the interim period of time what are
we doing for the children where can they
turn because at this point in time if
they're feeling hopeless and sad
so we wait until all of a sudden
something happens but what do we do to
be more proactive to allow the students
a safe place to go so they can report it
be given resources they need to deal
with it Jenny's great to answer that so
I think this is about connectedness and
so where can young people feel most
connected and safe to go that is where
they should go so it needs to be there
need to be a lot of options so we have
you know folks in internally inside the
schools that people can talk to having
trusted adults throughout our
communities is critical and we have our
you know crisis resources available for
Behavioral Health that really most
recently we've been doing so much crisis
transformation work and we've opened
that up both at the national level and
in New Hampshire where we used to have
you know the National Suicide Prevention
Crisis Line we're now looking at that as
a crisis line Lifeline more broadly and
trying to get Upstream so that people
can call tax chat well before a time of
Crisis so when young people are feeling
overwhelmed is the time to make that to
already start to make that connection
and get some of those resources my
five-year-old has told her whole class
when you need police fire or ambulance
you call 9-1-1 and when you're feeling
sad overwhelmed or angry you call 988.
follow up
thank you for that's very helpful to
hear that is there some initiative at
least within the school system or any
school or even a community that there is
that trusted adult that has been
identified if you will so the kids
children if you will know who that adult
is so when they call 988 which is great
but at the same time somebody within
their
environment that they know is a trusted
an adult that's been identified as truly
an interested adult that they can go to
so Department of Education has social
emotional Wellness Division and we've
worked closely with them to make sure
that every school district is aware of
our rapid response resources our mobile
crisis teams that can respond in schools
the resources provided you know through
988 that students can access so making
sure that our school districts have
information about all of the crisis
resources as well as every school has
you know has folks that are safe
um safe people to go to but sometimes
that might be very specific and a
Student Assistance professional which
works sort of like an EAP for adults but
it's for students right and and that may
be the identified person that doesn't
mean the student isn't still picking the
art teacher or the math teacher or
whomever to talk to it's going to be
about who they feel safe and comfortable
coming to which is why it needs to be
that everyone has the information
I I can't understand underscore that as
anymore it really is a community
response at the end of the day you know
children are going to find those trusted
adults in many places hopefully I mean I
think it is incumbent on all of us
within our communities to ensure that
there are places where kids can connect
and that's going to look very different
for very different kids we have sports
teams that some kids really connect and
they've got trusted coaches we have kids
who are in the Arts we have kids who do
music there are other you know 4-H we
need to build a resilient community that
is really focused on ensuring that kids
have relationships with trusted adults
and model positive peer interactions
I will just also mention that we do have
both Mental Health First Aid curriculum
a youth Mental Health First Aid going on
throughout New Hampshire that's already
available for sort of those Gatekeepers
which means just our general population
having an understanding of Youth mental
health per state and how to connect to
resources as well as nami's connect
program are just some examples of where
we are able to as community members
broadly get everyone sort of some amount
of training because really when it comes
down to it when a young person comes to
you with a concern it's about having the
courage to have a really difficult
conversation and having the language and
the resources right and so in the more
people we can train in those sort of
gatekeeper trainings the more often our
adults are ready when their kids need
them
because of the hour and the number of
agenda items I'm going to thank you both
for coming and keep us posted and I've
already asked um
councilor Williams to put on the
September agenda this group from
Manchester that has been referenced
chair now recognizes uh Courtney Keane
and Rhonda Siegel for the newborn
screening annual report
thank you
thanks
good morning chair Pearson and members
of the DHHS oversight committee my name
is Rhonda Siegel and I'm the section
head of maternal and child health within
the division of Public Health Services
and where New Hampshire's newborn
screening program lives
good morning I'm Courtney key I'm the
administrator for the newborn screening
program within maternal and child health
I think I'm sorry
the mic shut off
thank you
New Hampshire's newborn screening
program acting in accordance with RSA
132 10A an administrative roles atp300h
in calendar
2021 12
547 infants born in New Hampshire were
screened for the 37 disorders on our
panel this represents 99 of the births
there is an opt-out uh it parents do not
wish to have their child screened
um in that same calendar year there were
662 infants with abnormal screening
results so remember this is a screening
program uh not uh not a definitive
diagnosis of those infants 35 had a
definitive positive diagnoses
what's new in our program for the first
time since the program has been in place
we now have two uh fte's specifically
devoted to newborn screening in the past
we used to have to pull from other
programs nurses from other programs from
maternal and child health
to to work the program but now we have
wonderful time employee into part-time
uh this has allowed us to expand our
efforts in quality improvement and
particularly in follow-up both with
families and providers
so timeliness so just as an example of
our quality improvement timeliness and
newbird screening is key
birthing hospitals pay per filter paper
although Medicaid does pay
a certain percentage of that and
um an unsatisfactory specimen requires a
delayed time requires an infant to come
back and be re-screened again and it
also costs the birthing Hospital another
filter paper
so we are working on
um uh unsatisfactory specimens as part
of our quality improvement and in
calendar year 2021 uh the estimated uh
monetary figure for unsatisfactory
specimens was 32 996.
there are many reasons for
unsatisfactory specimens there's too
much blood to too little blood timing
it's not dry
Etc so what are quality improvement
staff has done and has worked with
Irving hospitals directly to reduce
these unsatisfactory specimens on a
quarterly basis New Hampshire's newborn
screening program reflects back to the
birthing hospitals and birthing centers
their quality improvement data including
unsatisfactory specimens time of blood
time to get to the laboratory Etc
so as I said I am the section head of
maternal and child health but I'm also
the co-chair of the newborn screening
advisory committee again regulated by uh
that same law and administrative rules
we meet on a biannual basis to hear
updates from the program uh from our
contracted laboratory uh the New England
uh screening program at UMass Medical
School
are contracted metabolic Specialists
who's a physician at Boston Children's
and often from experts and families when
we are considering another disorder to
the screening panel we consider new
disorders when a disorder has it's been
added to the National paddle of
disorders called the rust as well as by
families often Health Care Providers and
other Advocates and we welcome all to
the advisory committee
I'm going to go into a little bit about
the program
um so the two as Rhonda mentioned the
two main
um goals of the program are quality
improvement and follow-up
um and with that being said this past
year we applied for a first-time funding
opportunity through hersa we received
the award and this grant will help
support State's newborn screening
programs specifically around quality
improvement and follow-up so what that
means is that the program will continue
to work with hospitals and providers to
make sure that accurate information and
um
accurate information is put on the
filter papers in order to reduce some of
this unsatisfactory specimen Timeless
delays
um and then it is also going to help
um
with sorry um quality improvement
ensure that hospitals
work with The Courier Service to get the
lab filter papers to the UMass Medical
school for results the second thing is
follow-up and this is really the focus
of this grant is to ensure so we start
off with the screening right baby screen
there's potential out of range from
there we need to see if the baby was
diagnosed with a disorder from there if
the baby is diagnosed the goal is to
connect the family with other families
and to connect the family with resources
specific to their child's Disorder so we
know these over here disorders right so
how can you connect the small number of
kids with a group of families within New
Hampshire for support and also to
provide them accurate resources right so
there's lots of stuff out there as we
all know but this is what the goal is is
to make sure that these families have
accurate information and are able to
connect with other families within the
state of New Hampshire
um
the other thing that this grant will do
is it will support new online ordering
system so for hospitals instead of
calling the program to request more
filter papers it will provide an online
system so that they can just call me or
go online and order their filter papers
it will also
um provide what is our current vendor is
a newborn screening module So within our
data system so that we can follow this
child to make sure that it is received
all of the necessary services that it
needs
any questions
representative Weber
I'd just like to understand a little bit
better about this issue of the
availability am I right the availability
of filter papers and
it sounded to me as I was listening like
there were two possible places where
things can go awry one is having the
filter paper available initially and the
other is uh taking the test in a timely
manner and getting it to the lab in a
timely manner is that correct so and so
I'd like to know a little bit more about
where the where the bumps are in those
roads so
um we work with all of the birthing
hospitals and routinely send them a
large portion based on their numbers of
filter paper so there's no problem in
that sense the problem uh is uh is
really in timeliness you know how fast
it gets from uh so so take for a
disorder like galactosemia right where
an infant can't
absorb nutrients from formula from
breast milk right so if something fast
needs to be done that that test needs to
be done fast
um and so we it so it's Timeless we have
a courier that goes from every birthing
hospital to our lab in Massachusetts
um that has been uh over the last few
years uh sometimes great sometimes it's
not as great um we meant you know so we
uh can work on the timeline that's
actually something that the burning
hospitals
um have something to do with but not
necessarily right Timeless but uh when
the specimen is taken which should be
between uh 24 to 48 hours after birth
um how it's taken hospitals have a a you
know huge impact on that and that's you
know why sometimes unsatisfactory
specimens happen because of a variety of
different reasons overall
um you know our our hospitals are you
know are doing a great job of birthing
hospitals or birthing centers too we we
actually work with the birthing centers
to provide
filter papers so yes so I I would say
that it's just the tweaking inequality
Improvement but there's no problem with
availability of filter papers
what is what is your backup plan if and
when UPS goes on strike excuse me what
is your backup plan if and when UPS goes
on strike and cannot pick up
enough there's two different careers we
use so we use ups and City Express so if
there is an issue we will use our other
well the UMass will use their other
vendor Courier to pick up the specimen
thank you
representative Murphy great thank you um
so yeah I think you're answering the
question this is not a specimen taken at
the time of birth is it it is 24 to 48
hours after life so it's not done at the
time of birth it can be done afterwards
by a heel stick or something like that
correct and where is the lab that it has
to go to how far where is it physically
who does this Worcester so UMass Medical
Center yes there's no other in New
England that has that capability
uh we put out a request for proposals
every certain amount of years and uh
that particular program has uh you know
has has won the bid there were very few
I think they were the only people who
actually
um uh put a bid in put a proposal in and
uh
um they also serve as Maine and Vermont
and so there are they're a large lab
um you know they're very well connected
uh have a lot of staff
just follow up thank you um 99
screening is quite a number
is is that by Statute then I wasn't
aware yes it is yes thank you
representative
um Edwards
uh thank you Mr chair I think I have
three small things on on and I'll come
back for follow-up on page four this is
the back part or the last half of the
table showing the number of confirmed
cases yeah and so this this makes me
think
um
do is this an a good enough database
with other data sitting next to it so
that it can be sorted and
cross-referenced to things like
ethnicity or other demographics and
correlate it into zip codes so that we
understand where our health disparities
are yes so okay that's good yeah yes is
the right answer
on page seven uh and that oh follow okay
uh page seven there's a that last
paragraph there that starts from January
1. you you compare raw data 226 to 252
because we're simple people and we look
at Trends you may want to put that in
percentages so that we know what what
the trend is there thank you and and
then uh one more and this is the last
one okay and then maybe this is uh maybe
for Dr Murphy as much as any as you guys
but it sounds like there's a very fairly
sophisticated it program to determine
exactly what we test on these newborns
and I guess with our emphasis on lead
testing at an early age I'm I'm I don't
know what the efficacy or potential
would be of testing for lead here
because testing for lead at six months I
think is in the statute that that seems
to be administratively logistically
tougher for parents I'm wondering if if
there's a possibility to throw into this
mix the analysis of whether or not lead
testing would be relevant your thoughts
representative Murphy
I do not know how
um
the lead would be affecting a newborn in
because I don't know if it crosses the
placental barrier and would it be
relevant and not at the time of birth or
not would it be of something that would
have to be environmentally determined
after the child is born for a period of
time and therefore the six month window
I don't know enough about it to comment
on that but I also don't know whether or
not that the lead would actually cross
you know a placental barrier to affect
the child at Birth so would anybody on
the committee with an MD or do be
willing to research that absolutely
thank you sir
I do not have either an empty or a do
but I can tell you just a couple of
things one the legislation is for
testing for lead at one year not at six
months and part of that is just
behavioral as well that's when your
baby's out moving around and likely to
touch stuff that has lead in it
um the other point we are doing some
pilot work right now with some of our
home visiting programs to start
pregnancy to start voluntarily testing
lead among pregnant women and to your
point we can get you the clinical
information on there but we're starting
to understand that also
um not only for their health and their
infant's Health but also to be aware of
whether or not that's a healthy home to
begin with so if a mother even though
she might not have the same negative
health effects as a very small baby if
she's testing positive for lead that
that's a reason to do some investigation
into the home it's across though and
it's completely volunteer
any other questions
Senator Rosenwald just curious what your
screening rate is for home births
99 for all births in New Hampshire 99 is
for all so yeah so I don't know I would
have to look into specifically for home
births thank you because it's you're
just reporting a hospitals in this
document this is all birthston New
Hampshire
okay
representative Merchant
thank you Mr chair also thank you for
the report I also want to congratulate
the department I looked at the numbers
here on I think it was on page
where was it
the growth you've seen I think it was on
page six
um back in 2015 it was 78 percent he
folks now getting to 96 almost 97
percent
um now I think according to last one is
99 so I want to congratulate you folks
on that accomplishment there's something
to be
pointed out on page eight
one of the things you talked about is
short and long term and it's one thing
to identify a baby who has these
abnormalities that need to be treated
but following them and being sure that
they're getting the care and the
treatments and so what they need I think
is really critical but at the same time
there's a phrasing here about sharing
data
and I don't know whether that's going to
require a legislative change to have
data sharing so that you folks can
accomplish that because it's going to be
some way to monitor those children over
time
to ensure that they're getting the
treatment they need that's probably
going to require some sort of data
sharing amongst different providers is
there any barrier that legislative we
have to address to accomplish that
that's a great question
um we began the process to amend the
current rules to allow
um for confirmation of disorders from
providers
and then there is the potential that we
are going to develop not the potential
there is the need at some point to do
data sharing agreements with certain
individuals
so follow up so be clear at this point
in time you don't think we need to
legislative change to allow it to happen
um we did change the administ just
change the administrative rules so at
this point uh no but we're always open I
mean
so one of the things that we look at
when we want to add a disorder
um is you know the availability of
treatment or is there treatment for you
know oftentimes for some of these
disorders there is no treatment or you
know it doesn't matter at what time the
treatment is uh is provided but they're
costly the the disorders are very
closely to the family and
um so uh
yeah so so we just
um we think that we've developed the uh
administrative rules to help us to
um you know support confirmatory
diagnoses
um which is why you have 2021 data as
opposed to 2022 because it takes between
four or six months to about a year and a
half between the program and and uh the
health care provider uh that has the
confirmation
any other questions
Senator Rosenwald thank you when uh
when a um abnormal screening is picked
up is that not a result that's given to
the provider yes so
the provider responsible for providing
the case so the program is in contact
with the provider initially but it's the
provider's responsibility to take care
of the newborn that's correct the
Departments that is correct thank you
I was curious on page two about fees for
the filter papers and so on and I texted
uh Ms minnehan from the hospitals and
she reminded me that the great Committee
of Health and Human Services and elderly
Affairs last term passed the bill to get
the hospitals some reimbursement so
thank you for that reminder and thank
you for coming and making your
presentation and you may leave as soon
as we recognize uh representative quick
follow-up let can cross the placenta
into the fetus I knew that okay no no no
I wasn't aware you know I called for
doctors not Colonels with titanium not
lead so I mean I wasn't aware of that so
um but it can but the recommendation is
still 9 to 12 months for testing yeah
and now thank you
and now I am being
um reassured by my man on the ground
that all the remaining presenters will
be such that we can leave by noon so
that you're now recognizes Melissa Hardy
and Sandy pharaohs uh for an update on
the developmental Services redesign
implementation status
um and you are definitely one of them
good morning yes hi I'm Melissa Hardy
I'm the division director for long-term
supports and services Sandy is not
joining me today she sends her regards
but thank you for having us on the
agenda this morning
so I wanted to I'm here to give an
update on the retained house bill um 608
for developmental Services redesign
implementation so that was introduced
um this year for legislation as it
relates to piloting recommendations we
received from the Alvarez and marsal
report for developmental services so
we're still focused as the bureau on our
compliance piece of our plan which is
not part of the the piloting or the
recommendation so I think everyone here
is aware that our corrective action plan
through CMS has an end date of July 1st
so that is next Saturday we are counting
down to that date we have not began any
piloting of the redesign or any
discussions of the redesign as we've
been focused on being in our compliance
with our corrective action plan
so I wanted to just provide a high level
overview of some of the stakeholder and
family engagement that we've been doing
at the Bureau of Developmental services
from the last time I reported out so we
were able to and I won't go through
every single one we have here but I
think some of the highlights we did a
webinar series that were about two to
five minutes each snippet that were
directed towards families as it relates
to what does the compliance how does it
impact families what does it mean why
are we doing it so and we've gotten a
lot of really good feedback on families
watching those short Snippets of why are
we doing this it's really family focused
it went through our family
Communications
subgroup to make sure it was in language
that isn't government speak that's more
family friendly speak
um we did hold our first of our three
family meetings that we were having in
person and hybrid yesterday at the Brown
building we have two more coming up next
week one in Keene and one in Concord uh
sorry Keane and Conway excuse me
um that will be in person and have a
hybrid option so for families and
individuals to ask questions and have
discussion as they relate specifically
to our corrective action plan and how
that may impact individuals and Families
see
we continue with our provider Readiness
sessions so having multiple meetings
every month on
um having our service coordinators our
provider agencies come to the table
hearing from them how they feel ready
for the changes for them on 7-1 having
trainings as it relates to how they'll
be able to build directly to Medicaid
even going through the New Hampshire
easy system and showing our small
cohorts how you actually do that so
we've been working a lot on that the
past six six weeks or so meeting with
them and having a lot of just open
Office hours to be able to have them
come to the table and ask questions in
real time and so we can demonstrate you
know areas in which they may have
questions or concerns we can log right
into the system and show them
we also as 7-1 approaches we have
developed a dedicated telefilled line
and an on-call schedule that will be
staffed by BDS employees for providers
and individuals to contact us directly
with any concerns that they may have
leading up to the direct Bill process so
we have that staffed I actually cover it
on the weekends I don't know how uh you
know how many people will be calling but
we will be able to respond to folks our
our goal is within 24 hours but we've
been able to respond immediately to most
most inquiries since I know some
providers could you tell me that number
please
what's that oh tell me that number
please I don't have it on me but I will
get it to you okay thank you you're
welcome
um
we've also had two um under here under
provider Readiness we've had two
developmental Services Department roles
information sessions I know that's a
mouthful but
um we were getting some feedback from
the provider Community about who do we
go to for what so if we have a concern
about fraud waster abuse who do we go to
if we have a concern just about the
quality of services who in the
department are we able to pick up the
phone and make a concern to so we were
able to pull in different departments
from HHS including BDS The Adult
Protective Services the office of client
Legal Services Program Integrity
licensing and certification and we're
able to go through some real life
scenarios so if this were to happen and
you're a provider or if you're an area
agency who do you who do you go to and
whose role is it to follow up so we were
we got really great participation
in those two sessions and we think it's
something beneficial not just for BDS
but for the Department to continue to
have those conversations with different
providers so they know who to go to in
areas of concern
okay
and then finally some upcoming
engagement again we are having two more
um in-person family and individual q a
sessions in Keenan Conway we're
continuing our enrolled provider our
cohort Series so that goes up through
August
um which is targeted uh targeted cohort
sessions for our new newly enrolled
provider so we're able to spend
one-on-one time with our our providers
to answer their questions we also have
more New Hampshire easy trainings coming
up and we'll we'll be participating in
the Statewide family support
conference Workshop
um again kind of going over BDS systems
change work what's changing and why so
we're able to participate that within
that with the state Family Support
conference
so that's my quick update I don't know
first of all thank you so much
especially for the direct engagement
with families that's so important and
this is really encouraging to me
representative Edwards but thank you I
one of the uh topics maybe you can loop
back around to is I understand that one
of our conversion issues on the payment
system is that for about three weeks
we're going to be unable to routinely
make payments to Providers and that to
your credit you've come up with some
workarounds for that and given that we
probably all have providers in our
communities would you just tell us a
little bit about this this three-week
Gap what causes that and what you're
doing to mitigate the the problems sure
thank you for the question so we the
mmis system so that's the the Medicaid
payment system through the state will
have a blackout period for updates I
believe it starts on the 26th with the
latest
um
for it to be turning back on July 10th
we're hoping earlier than that for our
conversion but it'll be on at least by
July 10th so currently we are working
with area agencies on some contingency
billing plans also working with our
finance team so if we need to provide a
payment to an agency or a provider we
can do that within 48 hours through our
New Hampshire first system so if there's
a if there's a agency that's
experiencing a cash flow issue due to
the mmis system being in a blackout
period or if they're just billing
concerns we're able to issue them
payment through New Hampshire first
within 48 hours
any other questions
saying none thank you so much thank you
keep it up
and now we recognize for the monthly
updates Mr Henry lippman Medicaid
director
who's reading my text to him as he
approaches
foreign
good morning for the record Henry
littmann space Medicaid director
um what's being passed out is a little
snapshot on enrollment uh
I'm here today specifically on the
agenda to address uh what happened with
Grant Advantage I think everyone knows
that in hb2 we got a seven year
extension thank you very much for for
doing so
um I think that was a very good
compromise
um in terms of just uh what's being
passed around want to give you a little
snapshot on what's been happening with
granite Advantage enrollment if you look
at the top uh at the end of March at the
high point we're at 96 515 individuals
and granted Advantage
um and today
um just under we're at six on this chart
we're at 69 024.
um I can give you one small update that
I haven't had with down another
approximately 900 individuals as of the
19th
and basically in terms of enrollment we
structured our enrollment so that those
people who where we had a large
indication that they would no longer be
eligible of the first individuals that
are put through the unwinding aspect of
having to go through redetermination
and approximately uh 50 of the
individuals that uh
that don't continue to qualify on an
income base some people age out of
granted advantage and so forth I have
some information I can leave behind if
time is
an issue here in terms of what what's
been going on with the different reasons
for
um people losing coverage or closing
um you know I think that about 50
percent of the people just under 50
percent of the people that have gone
through redetermination have retained
coverage people also have a window of 90
days to to come back on without having
to file an application but the top three
reasons for people to lose coverage are
are income
failure to respond and then no longer
categorically eligible
and you know we expected our forecasts
in terms of what would happen based on
the protected population and the
information we had on the approximately
just under 104 000 people that we we had
good information on before the online
began you know we're we're tracking
pretty close to what we expected to have
happen at this juncture
you can see the standard population
where
we haven't seen the level of decline in
that that group and the way
the most vulnerable people
um the largest group of children and the
and the people who are on our waivers um
they're they're not going to be going to
their redetermination processes until
July August and September time frame
that I think is allowing us to perfect
um you know our communication and
Outreach and uh you know I know that uh
we're also seeing just
um we've referred as of the end of May
twenty thousand two hundred and two
people to uh the uh to the federal
facilitated Marketplace
the local Navigators just are kicking
off I think this week
um starting to do Outreach from the
federal perspective to these people who
may very well qualify for
exchange coverage let me stop there
on on granted advantage and an online
promotion
I just want to say to the committee that
associate Commissioner of DHHS Marissa
Hannah and I are both Milbank
fellowships fellows in public health and
we were in Seattle and I happen to
mention your name and a lot of people
around the country who really see what
you do here as the gold standard so now
that I've totally embarrassed you
um
it's true I appreciate that
um you and I had had a conversation I
was in Family Court as an observer last
week and discovered that it's great that
we're adding seven judges and support
staff to the Circuit Court we can't fill
the position the positions of support
staff that we have now which led to a
conversation between you and me and
wondering uh what connectivity is there
between you and say Rich labors in order
to say some of these people are rotating
off or they have been Unwound and yet
there are jobs needing to be filled so
that there can be some kind of more
intentional funneling could you speak to
that yes and
Associate commissioner santanella who's
worked a lot with Rich labors as well
commissioner associate commissioner
science
um you know I do think that we have
worked in the past and and we continue
to work with them in terms of the
special counseling that's available
sure good afternoon
um good morning Antonello associate
commissioner we do a lot of work with
New Hampshire employment security
um their job now work now program
provides free job training to anybody
who receives Medicaid snap or TANF we
actually as a result of our
um we had a
pipe burst in our Claremont district
office and so we actually relocated our
front office in the Claremont area to
New Hampshire employment security and
now their Claremont office because of
the joint referrals we're able to do is
their highest performing
office for New Hampshire employment
security and it beats like you know
Nashua which Claremont never has
um and so what we've been able to find
is it's a lot of the same clientele and
so when somebody's coming in and either
they're losing their Medicaid or they're
losing their unemployment insurance
we're able to in real time connect with
one another so we do a lot of programs
in that way and we also work really
closely when we did our Cliff effect
study and benefits so rich and I were
actually just emailing um earlier this
week about okay how do we help people
either in work now or in our snap and
TANF programs to really look at longer
range on employment opportunities and
we're talking about doing some video so
we work really collaboratively great and
thank you
something
um I do think that we have a question
representative Weber thank you
thank you
um I've had a couple of questions from
uh generally speaking from somebody
calling on behalf of a relative of
um a Medicaid recipient who by reason of
either age or infirmity or probably both
has not
um
uh done the appropriate paperwork and
then you have a relative who has no clue
what to do now and I was wondering if
you could give us a brief
uh suggestion because uh the people that
I've talked to when I say try the the
local DHHS office
have found that to be not very helpful
and one of the questions is how do we
deal about with these people who are
um eligible now and very very unlikely
ever to be ineligible again is what what
they were really asking about
um so I think there's a couple of
strategies I think sometimes depending
on what the ask is or the requests the
local district office can handle it or
um either in person or on our call we
also work closely with our service link
and provider agencies another piece that
we are working on is we have really good
resource materials but they're just not
in a prominent space on our website and
we're working to move some of those to
have them higher which really talks
through all of the pieces another piece
that we're doing
um along you know Henry and I and our
teams meet weekly daily all the time to
figure out is really working with some
of the partners that that support so if
that person is getting Services
um either through a nursing facility a
provider agency a case manager is
working with a lot of them to provide
the information
I I guess in the end if you have a
constituent that has an issue call me
and I'll try to get the right resource
on the problem and
um you know we fortunately have not had
been overrun with that I do get some
wires like that and sometimes you really
need to get some our best experts on it
because of a difficult situation and I I
very much appreciate that I just uh I I
guess I'm renewing my concern about uh
the access to information thing and I
you know I keep hearing oh now we're
going to do no wrong doors and and I
keep wanting to say I want fewer doors I
just want the right door and I want it
to be uh really really really available
to people I understand that there are
resource issues with service link and
and other things but and I very much
appreciate the networking and partnering
and uh trying to get all kinds of
different ways is for people to get the
information but I just want to say it's
still pretty frustrating out there
particularly for families who are
suddenly thrust into a system that they
don't understand
so I just want to it's nothing you don't
already know and aren't already working
on and just keeping it in the Forefront
there we are learning things from the
early part of the process that we're
making adjustments that will won't cure
it but I think we'll help it
representative Edwards thank you Mr
chair I I have uh two strategic things I
worry about on Medicaid and I'll just
tell you both of them and let you
respond uh the the first is I'm
concerned with the unwind that we're
going to be reducing the number of
carried lives to the point where we may
no longer have a market sufficiently
large to have at least three mcos
competing I I would hate to see us in a
situation where we only have two mcos or
one MCL I think you would too
should I should I keep worrying that we
may end up with fewer than three mcos or
do you you think we're going to be okay
the the second strategy thing is uh do
you do you see any roadblocks
or barriers that are going to get in the
way of getting the Medicaid
reimbursement rates input to to to
do go ahead and do the increases
so the on the first question we're
forecasting to be around the end of the
year
um this calendar year to be about where
we were pre-pandemic
um we in terms of enrollment
um you know with the economy stronger
um in the sense of at least the
unemployment number
um that that also has an impact on on it
so I think you know if there's a certain
economic impact standpoint but I think
we're we'll be pretty close when we go
up for procurement
um to be about where we were when we
went out to procurement five years ago
um you're as I mentioned too we're
expecting to see the way we structure or
unwind
the the larger number of uh people not
continue to be covered to happen earlier
because we had information or
um likely that they were not eligible
um but I do think that we'll settle up
settle out somewhere where we somewhere
near where we began
um
in terms of the the Medicaid rates we've
been working on getting ready for that
there's really three components to that
there's the across the board component
one of the first tasks that we have to
do in order to
um is to try to preserve the July first
date for that across the board to happen
where we're well on our way to to having
that done we need to do that before the
end of the month that involved quite a
bit of work because we have to give the
federal government an estimate of what
that's going to be and so we have to run
all sorts of analytics to you know run
that calculation and and we're in good
shape to be able to get that done the
second phase is looking at that 15.7
million which was at the commission's
discretion
um we're we're having conversations on
that
um and then the last piece is the the
larger component
um and so we're expecting to meet all
the deadlines that are in the legis and
hopefully do a little bit better than
that but there is
um you know there'll be some challenging
areas where we for example have to
change a a methodology in order to
utilize the funds that were appropriated
but I feel like we're we're going to get
there um it's just it's going to be a
lot of work but people understand the
importance of what needs to be done here
my question about blackout period can
you explain a little bit about that
please
um
generally I think when we're doing
um end-of-year close like this for the I
think as of March I mean excuse me June
23rd that uh we had to stop running
certain transactions through this
through the state system to bring
closing I think the blackout period is
probably connected to that that year-end
closed component
um and that I'll let you work yeah it's
also um related to the conversion
process that we have to do as we're
switching over to direct bill with our
provider so
um so we're hoping that it turns on by
July 10th most providers bill monthly so
we're not expecting a large cash flow
concern but if there are we're able to
to issue them payment
Senator rosenbault thank you
this eye test I love it but I think what
I'm seeing is that the
biggest reason people are disenrolled is
a failure to ready
what is the department
thinking about this are these people who
you just can't
find they've moved or
their phone isn't working anymore they
change their email how is the department
reaching out to these people who just
have failed to do the redeem but may
otherwise really be eligible so again I
guess in the early stages here I think
the information is different if you look
over time like for example in the first
month in the the bottom half of the eye
test there in the bottom chart if you
look in the month of March of the people
who are in the protected class 70 and
that was the people that hundred and
four thousand roughly population that we
have been working with for a lot of
times that 78.6 percent of the people
did not do a redetermination when you
jump out to to May that's down to 30
30.5 still a high percentage but it's
you can see that part of what's going on
there it depends on if you don't think
you're eligible you might not do that
but we're doing a lot to do Outreach
um and uh it would I can I have a whole
plan I can lay out to yeah yeah
yes
slide deck which is
incomprehensible to me but
um if I could just follow up if I'm
looking at the bottom half of that chart
though the biggest reason is failure
to to read the not
not income so it depends you saw three
months yeah if you look depends on the
group though is the the group that is
um if you look at the grand total though
for the first three months for people
who are in the protected group income
was the number one reason
um failure to reading was for the people
who were not protected was the number
one reason that was a a smaller smaller
group to begin with but that will get
group will get bigger over time we are
doing
um
a lot of Outreach we just put
implemented
um several things are implementing
several things in the month of June
based on what we've seen so far to get
after that one of the concerns we had
around children was this something that
was reported nationally that because a a
child because a parent lost their
Medicaid coverage who had a different
income standard that the assumption is
that the children aren't eligible so
doing Special Outreach on that including
direct phone calls to to those families
and particularly
we've analyzed information to
particularly to focus on those that have
um
shown that they've had medical
expenditures when we we looked at a
group of six thousand people for the
month of May and a little over six
thousand of that six thousand seventy
five percent of the people in that group
had zero zero claims in the recent uh
period and 90 uh 95 percent had
um
you know low dollar amount of claims
that we sugared off out of the six
thousand or so people to 333 people that
we knew where they were they were
consuming health care and that that we
needed you were having clinical uh
clinical team reach out to them and and
you know one of the things that the
national story with Kaiser Foundation
reported on is people don't understand
what's going on but what we found in the
the people that have been consuming
health care that they are much more
aware of what's going on because I think
they're paying attention that being said
we're also launching um you know we've
done the the pink letter the yellow
letter we've started a blue letter
Campaign which is if it's blue it's not
too late to renew
um and so
um for those people that
um have closed but still within their
opportunity to come back on without
filing a new application they're going
to get a special blue letter and we're
also going to be using
um texts and uh to reach to these people
with nudges uh several times a week for
a period of time and then also we're
adopting something that New Jersey uh
um is doing that the head of CMS
suggested that we might look at and
we're going to adopt which is a a red
and green postcard campaign and the the
the green is sort of like just before
they're about to close that they get a
card a postcard which is different than
we usually sent this is going to come
through the mcos as well
um and red if they've gone beyond in our
clothes to to encourage them to take an
action
um you know the we held not nine
meetings last week with the mcos and um
and invited providers to come in to see
how they could work together differently
I think our mcos are doing a lot of
creative things one MCO has created a
database where providers can go in
looking by their tax ID number to find
out who's due for redetermination and
easy look up another MCO is providing
um in their incentive program with 25 uh
deposit onto their sort of incentive
programs if they do their
redetermination I know that another MCO
is you know hired uh about fit to to
make calls so
um I think that you know the mcls have a
strong incentive to not lose enrollment
um
you know the department is doing things
we're also using the we even went um
this past Friday we last Friday we went
to out to the superintendents at the
prisons
um the county prisons that had
um you know they have people being
discharged who might come back on to
Medicaid to talk to them about what's
going on and they suggested coming up
with a one-page one pager that they
could hand out upon discharge from the
prison that they could hand to people so
we're working on doing that
we have a
you know I think
um I appreciate the the national
Expressions that I think we have an
enormous Outreach effort going on that
um in the end I think a lot of it is
being able to react to someone in front
of you or someone
um we're even still doing
um I think last week we did two
in-person events with the mcos with the
department and The Navigators come
together and try to help people in
person
um
representative Weber I just wanted to be
sure that the one pager for the prisons
is that being distributed to the county
jails as well that that specifically was
targeted for for the superintendents of
the county jails is who we met with
thank you well thank you for your update
and we'll see you in September sure I
have some dental information I don't
know if we've passed it out that I know
you don't have time for me but
um an update how could I have forgotten
Dental information
um do you have some slides for us we do
um we can for in the interest of time
yep it's an update on the network
um both the dashboard and a list of of
the participating dentists we had three
um in June we're having three van visits
in the North Country one um in Berlin
that happened last week and we got one
up in uh Colebrook I think two up in
Colebrook uh day is coming trying to
fill in there we've had over 3 000
appointments filled and I think that's a
statistic we're going to add to the to
the dash dashboard it's still you know
and I think uh Sarah Sarah it's Dr
Finney was saying that we're seeing an
increasing number
um of visits month to month still not
where we want it to be but um it's we're
working on thank you so much
and uh now the chair recognizes Michael
Holt for therapeutic cannabis items and
would you believe somebody in the
audience texted me how appropriate it
being high noon
foreign
thank you very much
um I know the hour is late I'm
I'm happy to defer to a meeting if you
can you give us like a seven minute
bird's eye view
okay great and come back so um
thank you
so there's two reports that I'm here to
present um the first is on the is the
therapeutic cannabis program annual data
report it's offer 20 uh 22 so it's
important to uh recognize that this data
in this report that has been handed out
is um as of June 30th 2022 so it's
almost a year old
um the scheduling of uh the presentation
has just such that you're you're looking
at older data I'll give brief updates on
what current data looks like as I go
through the uh
um the the highlights
um if you look on page three of the
report you can see a graph right up
front that talks about
um uh program growth since the beginning
of the program
um in 2022 we had a you know about a
thousand additional patients
um you know come on board over uh that
year the total is thirteen thousand
three hundred and sixty four registered
patients
um we have we have 13
602 patients right now and so what what
we're seeing is a um is a stagnant
growth uh flatlining stabilized growth
however you'd want to put it
um but the uh the the program has
reached saturation with the current
qualifying conditions that we have in
place
um and uh certainly with the regional
Outlook of cannabis being accessible you
know in every Market you know that
surrounds uh surrounds New Hampshire so
it is it is it is reasonable to
understand that uh many many folks in
New Hampshire
um are choosing to get their cannabis
across the borders without having to go
through a um an administrative process
and talking to their doctors
um we still naturally still has a
restricted list of qualifying conditions
um we do not give providers uh full
um discretion on what conditions that
they can certify patients for War
um and um
and there's simply there's a lack of uh
stores you know the set locations
throughout the state
um some are still you know very very far
away people are still very far away from
them so barriers to accessing the
program still uh still maintained and we
are now seeing that in the leveling of
the numbers of qualifying patients
registered in the program
um
if you turn to page eight you see a
graph about the age distribution of the
patients on the program
um they heavily skew towards 50s and 60s
um as you'd expect with chronic
conditions that the the Cannabis can can
uh help with
um I'll point out though that we you
know we do have someone you know I think
there's a 97 year old on the program as
well 96 year old 95 94 and we also have
um six miners
um on the program that number has remain
relatively stable throughout the history
of the program I think one year we had a
Max of 10
um but you know again very strong guard
rails in place
um for a minor participation
um and uh we believe that those guard
rails you know are appropriately in
place and and reflected by the small
number of uh patients uh minor patients
on the program
um it is a barrier to access though
because if you look at you know the age
range of 18 you know you'll see a uh
you'll see a jump right I mean page page
seven it's one one-year-old one
six-year-old one eight-year-old one 17
year old and then you get up to 18 year
olds 18 year olds in this 14. so again
it's not many but still that jump shows
that there's a that there's a barrier
um uh and perhaps a reasonable one you
know uh for uh underage teen
um
um the vast majority of uh patients more
than 75 percent of all patients are
certified by their providers for
um one of the one of the many pain
related conditions
um again this is uh this is this is
reasonable due to
um the uh
ample evidence that cannabis is
effective for pain relief other areas it
may not be as a as effective or the
science is still
um unsure however it's it's uh pain has
been demonstrated as being relieved
through cannabis use and so our numbers
reflect that as well
um in the area of certifying medical
providers if you want to turn to page 13
of the uh the report
um there's another graph that shows that
growth and uh recent stabilization of
the numbers
um again approximately 1300 certifying
providers
um in the state have certified at least
one patient
um so technically it's 1336 as of this
report and we now have 1328 so we are we
it's either stabilized or going down
over the past you know current year
um Physicians have absolutely leveled
off
um aprns continue to increase slightly
and uh PA isn't continue to increase
slightly as well these are the only
provider types that can certify even
though there are many other provider
types that have prescriptive authority
to prescribe control substances uh to uh
to to humans
um there's a bill this past session
um House Bill 610 which did not pass the
committee conference
um that would have expanded uh the
provider types to include optometrists
naturopathic doctors podiatrists and
dentists that did not pass although uh
you know we believe that you know
patients should be able to act access
this program through the providers that
they see on a regular basis so as an
example and you may have heard and you
may have heard representative Leon say
this on the on the floor
um some of you
um we've got 89 people with glaucoma
um
treating that glaucoma the optometrists
how many optometrists have certified
those 89 patients for the program zero
you know these patients have to go these
patients that are seeing podiatrists
um optometrists naturopaths and uh and
dentists even though they have
qualifying conditions even though they
have a relationship with these providers
they cannot access the program through
their providers because the law
prohibits these providers participation
so if anyone is interested in what we
can do
um legislatively that's going to be
refiled that is so you know
I'm sorry
that's true
great that's uh that that will be
helpful um better than better late than
never certainly
um
the um the last section of this report
um provides a summary of alternative
treatment center information the atcs
um you know are required to submit an
annual report
um patients served strains of cannabis
uh offered um forms of prepared cannabis
um nothing too dramatic uh really
different here this year than in other
years
um you know the the big thing that
happened in 20 uh recently is the uh the
allowance for uh in-state patients to go
to any of the atcs they don't have to
register with a particular ATC and so if
you look on page 18 and you see the
number of qualifying patients served
these numbers have kind of bumped up
because now patients are going
um throughout the state on going to all
the atcs to Avail themselves of you know
the the all the strains all the products
from the different companies
um that has also had an impact
um over the past couple years on
slightly lowering prices you know
there's now some what I would call some
friendly competition between the three
companies uh the non-profit entities
that serve the patients of New Hampshire
um because all the patients can now go
to all the atcs we've started seeing uh
uh prices come down modestly we've been
seeing sales
um and and whatnot so anything that
brings down the price of therapeutic
cannabis to patients is a is a positive
um
because insurance does not cover this as
a therapy and the prices in the regional
market have plummeted as of late and so
we see you know we just we we see
patients bleeding into other markets uh
regularly specially Maine
um which has the the lowest prices you
know in in the uh in the region
um
we're very interested in the
effectiveness of cannabis
um we'll get to that with the tcmob
report that comes later
um you know that all the atcs do uh
collect Effectiveness data like how is
this product working
um uh and the the rates of uh but it's
all voluntary right there's no
requirement in law in fact the law
specifically says that Effectiveness
data is voluntary on the part of
patients
um so the the the the participation
ranges from six percent one ATC to 35 at
another ATC
um the vast majority of people report
you know uh positive outcomes
um a very small amount report negative
outcomes
um our our patient satisfaction surveys
that we do every year
um as well they they show uh
surprisingly dramatic reductions in
prescription medications across the
board
um uh and uh high quality of uh High
satisfaction with the program at large
any questions representative mark
Merchant
thank you Mr
your comment about Maine being the
lowest what is driving the fact that
Maine is the lower of say New Hampshire
is it because of what what's the dynamic
and the other question I have is I
picked up in this report that there are
some times which patients have to drive
more than two hours to refill the
Cannabis and what we can do to
legislatively try to minimize that so
the first question is Maine and why the
pricing is so much different and
secondly how do we off the patients that
are driving so far thank you
representative Merchant
um Maine's prices are so low relative to
other states because the vast majority
of quote medical marijuana sold in Maine
is sold based on Maine's caregiver model
not through licensed dispensaries the
caregiver model in Maine is largely
unregulated meaning that there are no
state requirements for Laboratory
Testing uh there are no restrictions on
pesticides you use no restrictions or
labeling restrictions so for the most
part it is it is and I'm not saying that
there are bad caregivers or good
caregivers but there is no overhead
um uh for a regulatory overhead for
these uh and they proliferate they're in
every town there this is hundreds of
caregivers selling medical marijuana you
know to patients
um and they can sell at a ridiculously
low price
um to your second question
um state law limits the number of
dispensary locations there in the state
it also limits the number of licensees
so we have four licensees that operate
in uh in New Hampshire
um for licenses I'm sorry uh they're
awarded to three entities so one of the
nonprofits has
um two of the licenses each license is
allowed to have two dispensary locations
that's Limited in law
um back in 2018 and 2019 there was a
push to increase that from four
locations uh to eight
um still however you know um compared to
your number of Rite Aids and CVS's
throughout the state
um seven is uh seven is uh is is not
many
um Temescal Wellness which has the two
licenses
um including in the Seacoast they have
yet to date they have not opened up the
the the storefront that they were
authorized to do a number of years ago
um their management structure has
recently changed
um and we have started uh just recently
within the past couple months and we
have actively started uh working with
them on getting them to open up the
eighth store in uh in in New Hampshire
do you have a follow-up question
or does anyone else have another
question oh okay one more
thank you Mr chair so this is five years
of me basically asking the same question
uh I worry about the long-term
sustainability of our ATC Market I do
too because of uh competition not just
from atcs within that Community but you
know recreational pot around the New
Hampshire and and a in a black market
that probably exists fairly robustly I
know you don't pay attention to the
black market issues uh as a rule but I'm
just wondering if you're maintaining any
statistics to help us see the Delta over
time between the other alternative ways
of of a person self-medicating and
sourcing their own pot versus going to
uh the ADC ATC method because I'm I'm
just think
rationally over time if that Delta
remains large or grows larger that
that's going to do more harm to our ATC
structure and it will no longer be
sustainable could you comment on that
these are important points
um
we're seeing it now the the numbers are
flatlined 14 you know less than 14 000
patients in you know the state have
chosen to register uh many many more
people are self-medicating
um through you know and getting it
through other sources
um I can point to one piece of data so
uh we have
um it's not it's not stated specifically
but
if there are 13 500 patients registered
in the program as of this report and we
ask the atcs how many patients they have
seen and they say 11 000 we know the two
thousand of the patients have have never
gone to one of the atcs two thousand of
our registered patients are accessing
you know their cannabis you know through
any variety you know any one of those
sources that you mention
um there's a we you know I don't know
the difference between Black Market I
would call it gray market right uh um
and you know we've we've seen you know
we've seen THC products proliferate on
the shelves of gas stations in New
Hampshire as well hemp derived
um hemp derived THC products you know
and there was legislation this year to
uh to to try to address that issue
unregulated don't know what's in it
um and uh and so that was set up at 180
became 6 11 which did pass committee a
conference so
um I mean there's a lot of moving Parts
here you know the issue of legalization
I'm very concerned about that you know
and the department is concerned about
that in terms of the viability the atcs
and the viability of the TCP it is
important to keep the TCP in place under
whatever legalization model is adopted
by the state of New Hampshire
um and that is why that that we I have
Ben and others and the atcs have been in
front of the legislature throughout this
past session on all the legalization
efforts that you know have the potential
to making it
um House Bill 639 was decent it allowed
the atcs into the market
um to help sustain them as ant viable
entities
um a the the the last minute
effort to of the house to create a state
model legislation you know um or a state
a
state sales model legislation
um was proposing to take out what the
atcs not enter that market that would
have a profound impact on their ability
to be you know viable entities they're
non-profits which is a barrier you know
for you know their commercial potential
as well so you know we're
and the the question you're asking is
larger than are we tracking like actual
numbers like it's you know I don't know
the actual numbers of people who are
self-medicating and going to other
places but our numbers are flatlined and
a legalization effort you know in my
opinion needs to be evaluated in light
of the uh with and the goal of
maintaining the therapeutic cannabis
program well thank you Mr Holt we're
going to call it off here and if anyone
has another question they can approach
you privately after the meeting and
would Mr Lipman and councilor Williams
please approach like that was the one
that was one report
um
therapeutic canvas Medical
yeah
I know I know that and maybe we can
defer that to October
thank you because it's not going to be
answered briefly and it deserves to be
answered more thoroughly
yes yeah Mr chair yes
are we meeting in July and August no
thank you
the next meeting is September 22nd
Friday
could I ask
why we're not meeting in July and August
given the proliferation of items on our
agenda
and well I with a lack of ability to
thoroughly dig into the issues that
are of concern to all of us I'm going to
the speaker's office right after this
and I will pose that question okay
because I'm quite willing to do it
but I was told we couldn't so I have to
chase all statutory commissions are
allowed to meet throughout the summer I
will check it out again
okay that's it says so in the calendar
so so I just need to let you know I'm
going to be in Greece in July not that
you need to know that but I like saying
it
is so unlovely representative
review
thank you for raising that I will check
that back to get the official ruling
something
[Music]
the reasons foreign
I
foreign